la prescription ce retrait cabossé de ce
tour de table c'est l'unanimité
j'aimerais aborder un autre point man 2
autre point délicat avec vous en fondant
sur une récente décision de justice
il ya un homme qui a été condamné à 16
ans de prison pour le viol de sa fille
mineure qui l'a mise enceinte par
ailleurs mais sa femme aussi qu'il a
apparemment d'après la justice
connaissez les faits a été condamnée
assez sévèrement aussi quoique
évidemment moins sévèrement
quel est votre vous votre philosophie
par rapport à l'entourage
est ce que vous pensez qu'il doit en
répondre solidairement avec le bourreau
bah oui oui son complice
bien sûr bien sûr surtout s'il s'agit
dans des années qu'ils sortaient ils
sont complets oui pour moi oui ils sont
fiancés en courant oui non mais son
complice canon mais s'ils sont au
courant qu'ils sont pas s'ils sont pas
s'ils sont pas complices eh bien vous
savez bien eu cette information est bien
ils vont quand même protéger la victime
qui s'appelle ma question et si ce
n'était pas tout à fait ça c'est oui à
partir du moment où quelqu'un voilà est
jugé pour des faits d'inceste de viol
est ce que vous vous êtes pour qu'on
fasse vraiment une enquête pour trouver
qui était au courant qu'ils en répondent
devant la justice à traquer à les
traquer en tout cas et en une enquête de
l'environnement sur la vie remplie
squales à l'environnement à l'entourage
commencé avec la sphère duhamel quand
même qu'il ya tout un tas c'est affaire
du siècle comme on dit quand on sait que
tout autour en temps des accords
jacquelin ont parlé sur france inter sur
les amas book en train d'expliquer
comment c'était une vaste connerie
enfin s'il avait fait j'y allais c'est à
gerber franchement c'est à gerber c'est
impensable que cette espèce
d'intelligence ya là avec cette grande
association qui est le siècle saône et
rhône
ces journaux dans le tsunami sur
l'économie de l'île et moi n'y a pas
très intelligent de sièges pour dire que
tout les cas sur cette journée
ses origines vous explique fonctionner
la france
non mais je préfère actifs et tout de
suite parce que c'est une petite musique
qui se répand croyez moi n'y a pas que
des cadres supérieurs en cause c'est
partout notamment je vous dise et c'est
abject voilà on est dans le texte du
sénat il ya une députée et l'eire qui a
proposé justement d'allonger le délai de
prescription
le délit de non dénonciation donc c'est
sa partie alors cessé aussi ses petites
choses là qu'ils peuvent faire ce choix
mais c'est compliqué parce que
lorsqu'elles avec ami kouchner aurait pu
être poursuivi non elle avait 14 ans il
faut être fort et fait chaud mais s'est
passé une chose par rapport à par
rapport à l'entourage
on a toujours un effet calmant quand
vous me dites que votre mère ne vous a
pas soutenus évidemment c'est choquant
mais en réalité ce qu'on se rend compte
à travers le témoignage de camille
kouchner et bien d'autres témoignages
qu'on peut entendre c'est que souvent
l'entourage est au courant les six
systèmes de l'inceste perdure c'est
parce qu'en réalité le tabou ce n'est
pas l'un c'est le fait de parler à
scorer il ya de nombreuses familles où
ça se produit et il ya un système qui
s'organise autour du prédateur pour le
protéger parce que tous adultes sedan
c'est le personnage central dans la
famille et en fait on préfère le
protéger lui et exclure les personnes
qui sont victimes plutôt que d'engager
en fait une véritable une véritable
marque a remise en question d'être
personne est vraiment j'invite tout le
monde à écouter une série de podcasts
qui est super bien qui a été réalisé par
charlotte pudlowski qui s'appelle ou
peut-être une nuit qui raconte cette
histoire là en six épisodes
c'est accablant c'est à dire qu'on se
rend compte que c'est hyper répandue et
qu'en réalité la plupart des gens
préfèrent être lâche ou soutenir les
personnes qui sont adultes